THINGS OUT.
BENN REMAINS AT CENTER.
GREAT SPEED DOWN THE WING.
BY
SEGURA.
NOW, A WRAP LOOKED LIKE A
FIGURE SHORTHANDED,
GLENDENING IS ON IT. TO THAT, T
AFTER KLINGBERG SPRUNG
ROBERTSON, HE HAD OPTIONS.
I THINK HE MIGHT HAVE HAD COLE.
BACK TO LAWRENCE.
SOLATE
AND BRADEN GOT OUT, STOLE A
LITTLE BIT OF ICE
>> Josh: SKJEI, THE DEFENSEMAN
IS IN PULLING AWAY.
OFF NIEDERREITER
ATTACK.
NICE MOVE, NECAS, SHOT, SAVED.
HOLTBY, CING
RACE.
>> Daryl: STARS TRYING TO EXIT
THEIR ZONE.ES TROCHEK.
SHOT S S IT.
ANSWERS RIGHT AFTER THAT,
JARVIS. DEFLECTED OFF THE POST.
PAVELSKI, THE FLY-BY. BE PAVELS.
I THINK IT HIT THE POST, AND
AND SOMEHOW THEY HACKED,
WHACKED, AND GATHERS, AND A
IN THE NHL.
SVECHNIKOV
DENIED.
SVECHNIKOV.